courir pour récolter des fonds pour
aider la population du burkina faso
c'est la belle action des collégiens de
miles a bourdonné une action qui s'est
déroulée dans le jardin de l'état mais
avant de prendre le départ petit
débriefing et par-delà 104 avec la
classe de cm2
la règle est simple plus on courrait
plus on gagne de l'argent aux côtés des
collégiens des primaires qui eux aussi
participent à la course contre la faim
les objectifs sont en effet de
sensibiliser les jeunes au problème de
la faim dans le monde et surtout leur
faire prendre conscience de l'urgence
que représente ce fléau il s'agit aussi
de créer un élan de solidarité les
élèves qui rend la course ont assisté à
une séance de sensibilisation avec un
bénévole d'action contre la faim
voyez au burkina faso des veaux un peu
lâche on peut acheter médicaments du que
nous menacer un minot n'a pas besoin
payer tout ça mais la leffe et piscine à
des trajets les moyens la maman malines
l'humain strong comme sable comme a vu
le film de tfz pitt c'est comme ça vanne
et récoltent de l'argent pour acheter à
manger et pour les tout petits
le mot d'ordre est simple il faut aider
le burkina faso à manger
et il y en a très content on a compté
pendant longtemps a sciemment j'ai alors
il faut parler
rachid l'est pas nous il faut que
j'essaie de faire le plus de tours
possibles et les toits pousser ce qu'on
a
pour le personnel enseignant qui courent
aux côtés des élèves il s'agit de
véhicules et plusieurs valeurs à travers
les vertus du sport et pour l'action
contre la fin donc on mobilise nos
élèves action citoyenne pour récolter
quelques fonds pour la faim dans le
monde notamment la malnutrition des
enfants
cette année c'est pour le burkina faso
et je vois que les élèves sont bien bien
motivés et l'équipe éducative aussi vous
vous aussi vous courrez vous comptez
récolté combien d'argent au total à bas
on verra on verra on a 200 élèves
on a une équipe éducative difficile de
donner une somme pour l'instant là je
finis mon sixième tour et j'espère en
faire une allez on va dire 20 une course
mais pas une compétition
il s'agit d'un projet citoyen solidaire
et sportif
ça fait partie des actions destinées à
porter certaines des grandes valeurs de
la république liberté égalité fraternité
certes mais aussi citoyenneté est ici
solidarité ses actions autour d'eux des
valeurs de solidarité ne se réduisent
pas à courir autour d'un terrain au
profit d'une bonne cause
en fait ici c'est le point d'acné d'un
un ensemble d'opérations de
sensibilisation menées aussi bien au
collège mahé de labourdonnais que dans
les écoles de secteur pour que des
plusieurs centaines d'élèves ici ils
sont deux cents soit touchée concernés
par ici les problèmes de la faim dans le
monde
une course qui a nécessité une
organisation tout le corps enseignant a
mis la main à la pâte pour faire de
cette journée une réussite
henné simplement puisque l'association
démarche les écoles et les
établissements scolaires pour participer
à leur oeuvre et nous avons présenté ce
projet aux équipes et aux élèves qui se
sont montrés très enthousiastes et à
partir de là donc on a engagé plusieurs
actions en annonce un établissement tant
d'un point de vue sportif que d'un point
de vue pédagogique puisque les élèves
ont été sensibilisés à ce problème de la
malnutrition dans le monde et en
particulier au burkina faso et du point
de vue sportif donc ils ont été
entraînés
endurance à pouvoir courir le plus
longtemps possible pour cette initiative
en 2014 la 17e édition de la course
contre la faim a mobilisé 1093
établissement scolaire soit 266 1000
jeunes en france et à l'étranger